Turned around and go, wow, I really
don't know what I'm talking about.
A lot of times I really better
think about what I say more.
And even now I'm just a lot more careful
about making absolute statements.
I don't make any more absolute statements
or things like that because you want
to be sure that you're conveying
the right information to people.
What were you saying before
the podcast started? You were,
we're going to bring it up again about
veganism coming from a religion. Yeah.
Yeah. Veganism started, um,
with the seventh Adventist church
I believe. So there was, um, uh,
you know,
a group of people that had a church and
the guy that led the church as part of
the church was like,
you know,
they were following the Jewish kosher
laws or whatever at first and it was like
no pigs or whatever else, a shellfish
I think. Yeah, no pigs or shellfish.
And then the guy just said like,
it just sort of took it to the next
level and said, and like, no, no meat,
no animal products at all.
And so these people that were in this
church were like the first real group of
vegans.
The Church of seventh Adventist I think
is what it was called is where it came
from. Like 1863 is when that
movement I guess started it.
I'm like sure I'd started early.
I'm sure people were doing it
earlier than not obviously,
but I think that that's where the,
the roots came in.
I just find that really interesting
because it does, you know,
it does seem like a
religion. It seems like. Um,
today it seems like a lot of times you
get, um, I get called out a lot on,
on Instagram and stuff like that from
people that are Vegan saying like,
I can't believe you'd
do this and blah blah,
but I would never go on their page and say
anything to them at all. Well, so there
proselytizing, I mean that's, that's a
big part of this whole community is it's,
there's a moral high ground. They stand
on it. And then a lot of these people,
especially people with Vegan in
their name and their screen name,
they always go after people and they try
to shame people and what they're doing
is in oh in many ways
is a very good thing.
They're not participating
in factory farming, right.
They're not participating in the horrors
that we see in these fucking peta
videos where you see cows and pigs
and chickens are just being tortured,
all that fuck,
that is disgusting and that should be
eliminated and it shouldn't be a part of
modern culture.
But in terms of like the humane
raising and killing of animals,
look, they're not going to live
forever and I don't care what you say.
I'm not into animal suffering.
I don't think they should suffer.
But if you try to say the people are
not herbivores or that people are
herbivores rather, and then
we're not omnivores, you're
crazy. It's just not true.
It's not fact. And they show picture.
These are not the teeth of a carnivore.
These are the teeth that were were not
carnivores. Stupid. We're omnivores.
Check stands and everything. Yeah, we,
we look real similar and
our teeth to fucking chimps.
Chimps are omnivores and the human
diet is a very complex thing.
When you attach that
human diet to ideology,
then it gets really screwy
because you're not dealing,
you're not dealing with people that
are being honest about dietary,
like what is really important and
as far a dietary requirements,
how your body functions, what the studies
show. If you look at it objectively,
the objective, the first thing anybody
should say first thing of cross the board,
Garrett, all the fucking
sugar. That's number one. Yeah.
Get rid of all the refined carbohydrates.
Eat more vegetables.
I think you guys don't eat more
vegetables. Eat healthy fats.
Get some formal omega fatty acids.
Recognize that the omega fatty fatty
acids you get from flax seed oil or not as
bioavailable is fact from studies
not as bioavailable. Is it?
Mega fatty acids you get from fish
and meat, you're just not the meat.
The protein you see well broadly has
15 groups. It's not as bioavailable.
You fucks and you know it's not,
it's just not.
So you can get bioavailable
protein from plants.
You get it from him, you get it
from keenwah. You get it from peas,
pea proteins where it good,
but it's not as good as the,
the protein that you get from meat. It's
just not, can it sustain you? Yes it can.
Can you be a healthy person and live
a fucking bounced life on a completely
vegetarian diet?
100% but I would always
recommend eat free range eggs.
You're not hurting a chicken. Nothing
gets hurt. It is free food. We have,
I have chickens. They roam around,
they eat vegetables. Nobody eats them.
The chickens live a fucking healthy
life. They lay eggs, we eat the eggs.
The eggs are healthiest.
Fuck ethos.
Find a place that has free range
chickens. Eat the eggs. It's,
I mean it's not Vegan,
but it is vegetarian.
If you want to get rid of dairy
and you don't want, I get it, man.
I've seen Gary dairy farms.
It's fucked up.
You see what they're doing at cows
and they, you know, the way they,
they treat them and the way they're
raised them and just the whole idea behind
it, like making them lactate.
The only time cows lactate
is when they have a baby,
right? So they keep them in this
state and it's just, it's unnatural.
And that is a reality of dairy production.
And if you don't want to be a part
of that, that's 100% knowable.
But we have to be honest
about nutrition requirements,
not about the ideology of veganism.
And this is the problem with these people.
And so many of them, especially the ones
with Vegan attached to their identity,
because they use the name
like I'm Vegan Warrior,
this is Vegan prints
and the Vegan defender,
they're fucking morons who joined a gang.
And what they do is they
start eating plants,
they start talking shit and they go
looking to just go after anybody who's not
on the same page as them. And the real
problem is people that watch a movie,
like what? The health or something and
then think, well that this is, oh my God,
I'm killing myself by not being a Vegan.
Nope,
you need to Google what the health
debunked and find out the actual science.
Cause what they're talking about is
bullshit. They're not being honest.
What they've done is make a
Vegan proselytizing movie.
They're trying to get people to join in
because that's what they do and a lot of
these people,
they give up a lot of these people that
get to a point where the health can't
take it anymore and they fucking give up.
Chris Kresser is a perfect example.
I don't know if you've, have you
interviewed him for the film? Not yet,
but we will. He's fucking
brilliant. And he was a macro,
but he was a macrobiotic Vegan.
I mean this guy was all off the charts
with veganism and eventually realize his
body was falling apart and gave up on it.
There's some people that own that
restaurant in California and Hollywood.
What is it called? The something cafe.
Thank you. Can I think gratitude?
Yeah. These people were, they mean
they're fucking health was falling apart,
so they decided to raise their
own cattle and eat throwing.
Me and vegans found out they got death
threats and people were fucking going
after them. Yes ma'am. It was a
terrifying thing for these people.
They're all our folks. And they, they,
they have their own farm and they were
raising their own farm animals and they
decided to start eating them. And when
they made these posts about starting in,
these people went after them. And you
know, it's not, this is not kindness.
And you know,
this is not someone who is compassionate.
He's a fucking cunts that are in a gang
and that they're in the plant gang.
You know,
and if you talk,
and I'm sure you've seen it by
doing this carnivore diet thing,
if you do anything that's outside of that,
they go after you.